when robert pops up in wayne's world i  remember the whole movie theater just  screaming was he proud to have created a  character so iconic that t1 would be  instantly recognized even in a different  genre  that was part of how i started to  realize that it was uh  such an iconic role  that was when it started to dawn on me  laura michaels yeah  when he insisted to mike myers that i  play the cop and mike myers was  resistant and didn't want me to play the  cop  but when  lauren michaels insisted and had me play  the cop  and it got such a big laugh probably the  biggest laugh in the movie  and um i'm sitting next to penelope's  ferris in the chinese man theater and  we're both kind of like it she goes she  leans over and goes  i think you've got the biggest laugh in  the film